in this video i'm going to have a
discussion with the creator the original
creator of symbolic python
dr hombre charity i guess i didn't i
never felt i need the the computer
science classes to learn how to
programming i think the best way to
learn programming is to sit down and
start programming because i worked
really hard on it i realized oh this is
a really huge potential and so i worked
really hard on it for half a year to a
year pretty much every day every night
so doing the school and then i came home
and just
you know worked through the whole night
through this process you have been a
mentor to many many students
and quite a few of them have been from
india especially for symbolic python it
just so happens that many of them have
been from india i think quite a few of
them from the iits also learn python
stick to python you know
you have to know python because
scientific computing may be different
term uh python is the king so yeah what
was your experience like at lawson like
it's a it's a legendary place uh in the
world in the public imagination the
manhattan project
the the atom boom
and the and the entire stories that uh
professor richard feynman had narrated
in his books
you know i published a blog post called
resurrecting fortran and a lot of people
objected they say no fortran was not
that you know it's easy to run in
fortran i get decent performance and
then i rewrite to c plus plus and i get
slower performance what is your work
setup like what what
what operating uh system you use which
editor you use do you have any special
workflow which helps in your
productivity funding for uh students so
if any of you are interested uh
listening and if you are interested in
working with us let me know just contact
me email me if you're interested email
me
[Music]